he's one of these religious types gabe
said he really
he he's almost like the pied piper of
the in cells if there is such a thing oh
yeah i know who you're going to bring up
you know he claims to be a doctor he's
not even he's he really likes to attract
american incels but he's he's actually
canadian um and a lot of people you know
in the chat this
uh he's a clinical psychologist if i
remember correctly is that what he calls
himself
just like just like uh rand paul is a
doctor right right right right right
well he needs to have his [ __ ] head
checked by someone because he tweeted
this uh let me pull down the uh the
okay i'm gonna pull up a clip
uh talking about something similar okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna comment on this
while you're doing that
dr jordan b peterson and apparently he's
left twitter because of this because he
was just too bullied i guess or some
[ __ ] i don't know he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
is what he is and it's not surprising
because he said sorry not beautiful
about this uh the newest
the sports illustrated swimsuit edition
uh
human new is the is the model on the
cover she's [ __ ] smoking hot she's
[ __ ] beautiful absolutely [ __ ]
gorgeous if anyone can't see it here she
is [ __ ] beautiful
and he says uh that's gonna call it out
i mean the guy is [ __ ] jealous right
well
he's not being oh i mean no one's listen
no one's gonna look at him and say yeah
you know what i want to put him on the
cover of sports illustrated
jordan peterson is a [ __ ] cuck
he is definitely a cook and she is she's
[ __ ] gorgeous that's why they put her
on the cover yeah of sports illustrated
what in the [ __ ] how
anyways as if they made a mistake here
he said sorry not beautiful and no
amount of the authoritarian tolerance is
going to change what the [ __ ] does eddie
i don't even know what that means does
he mean that people are forcing people
to say that this is beauty what are you
talking about you fool
how can you not objectively say that she
is absolutely drop dead gorgeous i don't
care like
who you who what your type is or if you
if you are sexually attracted to women
or not jordan i mean you know it's
questionable but she is absolutely
gorgeous
absolutely gorgeous
and
i said i said and i think this is where
i was going with the ball thing hundred
dollars 100 hours says jordan peterson
tans his balls now i haven't been wrong
about a lot gabe i have not been wrong
wrong about a lot um i've been correct a
lot lately so maybe i'm right on this i
don't know if someone wants to take me
up on it but um
but i bet i don't i don't know if anyone
now they would want to like look like i
you know i respect you for the uh the
the prediction and claim that you have
here but i don't know if anyone in our
in our group is willing to get that
close and personal
to know if jordan peterson is tanning
his boss oh so it's so it's kind of it's
kind of like about the proof thing more
than anything is that what you're saying
yeah yeah i just don't i don't think
people want to put themselves through
that you know i don't know that's uh
right you might have to you don't have
to you might have to you might win a
hundred dollars but then you have to pay
someone the hundred dollars just to go
and find the truth just to go right
exactly
just to look it up speaking of ball
tanners i almost guarantee this
[ __ ] dances balls too oh i i
would probably put a thousand dollars
on this [ __ ] tan in his bowls
have you seen the the pictures of the
dudes like laying out naked with their
holding their feet up in the air like
tanning their tan and their ass squatch
like they're oh like they're trying
they're trying to like sunlight their
[ __ ] right right well they're trying
to suntan their their nuts and their
butts the nuts and butts at the same
time nuts and butts i i would almost bet
that there is a time that uh joe rogan
has stripped down and tanned his nuts
and butts at the same time almost
guarantee it no no doubt no doubt about
it
you got for me here with the baltimore
here this is a this is a clip between
joe rogan and uh jordan peterson and
they're talking about you know rogan
talk well i mean let the club speak for
itself but basically they're talking
about um
uh uh pigmentation uh and also oh
skype skin color like yeah exactly so so
are they talking about tanning here or
is it just like racist type [ __ ] no it's
just like racist oh okay
tan and it's like oh dark tan black
white like that whole spectrum of like
what shade you are
is discussed here and jordan peterson's
response is [ __ ] top
oh i bet it's racist as [ __ ] janie says
tanning their taints they are we're
gonna watch two tank tanners talk about
other people's
pigmentation apparently i think i've
seen this clip before but you know
jordan peterson is a regular on joe
rogan's podcast because his audience is
jordan peterson's audience like it is
the cockiest of the cucks is joe rogan's
ability to have someone on as a guest
right and then immediately the next days
be like yep so this is what i believe
and i had this person on who was an
expert right and now i believe anyone
can say they're an expert and joe rogan
is the ultimate prime example
of the dunning-kruger effect right right
the facebook ivermectin group believing
it full stop just because you just read
it right let's listen to the clip
depending on who you ask either you're a
voice of reason and rationality and
and uh you know
personal responsibility oh [ __ ] this
guy's gonna talk about reasonability and
rationale and oh my god oh [ __ ] this guy
or
you're a voice of intolerance
and bigotry and anger and hateful sexual
oppression what did michael prejudice
dyson call you and me mean every white
man yeah and and a mean angry white man
hilarious uh so they're talking to about
the eric dyson there um he's a professor
i believe um he's a he's a he's a black
guy obviously um that's why they're
upset that a black dude would call them
ra how dare you
how dare you call me racist when i say
racist things you son of a [ __ ] let's
listen
and by the way i want to point out um
it really is not surprising that this
the guy who's saying that she isn't
beautiful you dumb look at this [ __ ]
yeah look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] keeper
type [ __ ] in a bow tie and it
ain't surprising that he's on the same
spectrum as tucker carlson these bow tie
wearing [ __ ] not this i'm not
discriminating against bow tie wearers
it just seems that there's a pattern
here let's listen
yeah yeah you're not mean at all that's
what's dumb about that statement it's
you're not mean at all it's i am white
he's racist you're just not mean
what the [ __ ]
like literally joe rogers like look that
that where he called you a mean bigoted
racist you're not mean yeah i mean of
course you're a racist bigot but you're
not mean about it right you're like
white racist and bigoted you're not or
like right white mean and bigoted you're
not you're not mean you know it's like
these three things only one can be true
right or rather one can be false it's
like two truths and a lie you know how
dare he call you mean that son of a
[ __ ] what an [ __ ] called you mean
you're not mean i mean you're a [ __ ]
bigot and we're about to find out how
big it you are
actually that's a lie too i'm kind of
tan and he was actually not black
because i'm i'm darker than you that's
ridiculous yeah but
okay so go go back go back and and hear
what he says
let's listen to it again actually that's
a lie too i'm kind of tan and he was
actually not black
he was sort of brown
so jordan peterson is trying to make the
argument and so is joe rogan
that black
is is like uh is like black like my hat
right or my shirt right exactly not an
indication of like oh that is your race
your black white whatever they're trying
to say well he's actually like light
brown he's not actually black and then
they're going to go into a whole thing
about how like like what is what is
black why do they call them black you
know like it's
wait wait you're telling me you're
telling me they're not only going to be
racist they're going to be mean too
about it right babe you're not mean
they're not then you've got jordan
peterson over here who is probably
whiter than the goddamn t-shirt he's
wearing in his wannabe 80s tux right now
and he's going to try and say that some
black man is not actually black and he's
not actually white
homie
i could probably see through you you're
a [ __ ] ghost you're that white [ __ ]
this is ridiculous that this guy says he
it you know the most i mean he's going
to say some racist bigoted [ __ ] here but
the most ridiculous thing i think he's
said so far is that he's tan
why
he's like i'm not actually white he's
like actually that's a lie too i'm not
actually white i'm tan and then goes
yeah and i'm i'm darker than you what
what's up with this right like what what
you're seeing is not real what you're
seeing is not maybe maybe this is just
more proof that i'm right that he tans
his balls because maybe he's talking
about his balls or tan because we all
know that these cucks only
tan their balls right right manly so
maybe that's it maybe that's it i don't
know
because i'm i'm darker than you yeah
yeah that's ridiculous yeah but neither
of us are white well i'm italian and he
was brown not black well isn't that
weird yeah it's really weird the black
and white thing is so strange because
the shades are shannon brown there's
such a spectrum of shades of people
unless you're talking to someone who is
like 100 percent african from the
darkest place where they're not wearing
any clothes all day and they've
developed all that melanin to protect
them what what the [ __ ] is he talking
about
what what is he talk like only people
from
the darkest place where they don't wear
clothes is the per what the [ __ ] is he
talking about yeah he's like only a real
black person is someone in africa who is
totally exposed to the sun everyone else
yeah they're brown yeah they're not
black
and you and i we're not white we're
brown
cynthia points out a good point here oh
my god is this parody no they're they're
talking like seriously yeah this is them
actually having a conversation trying to
make themselves seem relevant by saying
how they're actually not the white guys
right they're not actually racist and
they'll be racist they're not white
they're not white and by the way how
dare anyone
anyone insinuate that they're mean that
is ridiculous that is that if they're
gonna be offended by anything
it's that you said they were mean and
that's not fair
jordan peterson let's let's finish the
[ __ ]
bigoted launch here because we know the
dismount is bigoted as [ __ ] themselves
from the sun
you know it's even the term black is
weird so it's a and when you use it for
people that are
literally my color
it becomes very strange yeah yeah you
know
this is true it's like so you were
asking
but when you use it for people that are
my color
again again is calling
a white person like joe rogan black
well what he's saying what he's saying
is if there's light-skinned black people
they're not black right they're not
black if you're light skinned you're not
black you're not black it's this you
know
oh my god it just it never stops with
these [ __ ] so that's jordan
peterson yeah yeah and it is no wonder
so according to jordan peterson he's not
actually white
and he's not mentally not mean he's
definitely not mean he's definitely he'd
never address the racist part the
bigoted part
well i mean why would he why
why would he you don't have to address
it when you just double down on it right
right absolutely absolutely well and
jordan peterson not only is he is he a
[ __ ] bonehead and he's an incel and
he's a racist bigot but it's not
surprising he's super religious like he
uses religion and he said he he does
these really weird diatribes where he
says all these really big words to
impress uh in cell white dudes but he
says nothing he seems like absolutely
nothing that sounds a lot like uh
ben shapiro yeah you know it it is funny
how charlie kirk ben shapiro jordan
peterson and some of these others are
like the pied pipers of alpha cux it
really an insult alpha cuts it really is
funny how
all that that venn diagram just seems to
be a [ __ ] circle weird just a [ __ ]
circle